I understand you are a Joseph Campbell
fan you like him so I found this quote
and I think this is one of his more
popular quotes we must be willing to get
rid of the life we've planned so we have
so it is to have the life of waiting for
us something to that effect
yeah how is this true in your life I
love that quote I'm a huge Joseph
Campbell fan like I think I I am in awe
of his the way he used words in the way
he experienced life with such a raw
sense of understanding light in darkness
and and and so it in my own life I would
say that the quote is all has to do with
the present as well like I think say for
example when I wanted to be a vice
president of current programming that
was a 13 year journey for me from the
assistant level to the vice president
level and I think in my mind and this is
something I work with writers on is I
was so attached to the destination that
at times I didn't value the journey in
the way that I could have and I think
that you know when we when we do attach
to what the future is supposed to be
then we're taking ourself out of the
present and we're attaching to something
and we're not being in something and I
honestly think the greatest part of the
writers journey is learning to be in the
journey versus attached to the
destination so keeping with the idea of
getting rid of the life we've planned
you know we're in LA and so many people
myself included we all come here from
somewhere else right with an idea of a
destination yeah and I think you'd said
this before people under 30 definitely
have
an idea of how things look on the
outside is very important yeah and
probably in LA it's it could be beyond
32 but yeah when you speak to writers
that are maybe under 30 I don't know how
many of them are actually approaching
you to look at their work but how do you
sort of guide them through that I don't
know maybe that's not what you do but no
it is what I do I mean I definitely I've
had so many writers say you should be a
therapist and I I'm definitely of the
belief and if there were anything else I
was doing I would do in this world it
would be that and and I think that
because emotional response to life
fascinates me and and definitely going
with that okay so going with the idea of
I can start a consult with a new writer
who is like all right Jen I want to
write this pilot I want to sell this
pilot and I want to be a working writer
by next year now depending on what the
journey has been so far if this is a
brand new writer that has that
aspiration then it will take me looking
at the writing and understanding where
they are in the process
oddly enough I have had writers that are
newer writers where they express that
aspiration and I think it could be a
reality if the right actions are taken
to lead to that outcome where is I can
work with the writer who says Jen I want
to be in your top 5% and I want to be
working by next year where's that is not
a realistic expectation and so I think
it really is I think what people have to
understand more than anything and again
it goes into the quote and I probably
went out cited a quote with with the
example I gave but let's say within what
I talked about I my pursuit was to run a
stew
that's what I thought I was being
groomed for that's the destination that
I thought I was moving toward and my
journey got interrupted it got
interrupted when my contract wasn't
picked up after 15 years with two sister
companies so it was on the heels of a
situation that came out of nowhere so it
was like I had five shows coming back I
had never been warned about anything and
then in a moment due to a choice that I
made 15 years were gone and I was no
longer going in the direction that I
thought was my destination and that
caused me to have to redefine in many
writers I will tell this as well I mean
you know certainly being the writing
instructor for writers on the verge of
NBC we have to tell the eight final
writers that get chosen out of 2,000
that yes you made it to this point but
there is no guarantee that you're going
to be a working writer what this step
does is it gives you greater opportunity
to give you the outcome that you desire
however that is going to be up to you
and the work that you put in to this
opportunity and so I think guiding
writers to recognize that they may have
to redefine what that destination is in
order to really find joy in the writing
process well that's excellent because it
kind of leads into what I was going to
ask next and that is have you seen a
writer approach you under 30 over 30
driven more by ego and then they've kind
of come back to you or you've run into
them several years later and you can
tell that all of that it's now they need
to do this and has nothing to do with a
title it's for though yes oh yeah that
that's a great question I
you know when we look at character we
look at the internal aspect of the
character in the external and it's the
same in life when we look at the writer
and we think the internal aspect many
stories I say the first three quarters
of the story the hero wants to achieve
the goal for ego related reasons then
through hitting obstacle after obstacle
leading to the Olive lost moment they
are humbled and then there is a
recognition that the achievement of the
goal isn't just about them it's about
the greater good and it's the same for
the writer the writer has to go through
that in the life process they have to go
through many writers when they first
take on the journey they want to become
a working feature writer or working TV
writer because they want to validate
themselves because they want mom and dad
to think that they are all that because
they you know want to make bucket bucket
loads of money and there's the desire is
not aligned in a strong way because the
ego is driving the outcome and I think
through the writing process and learning
that there are gonna be so many hard
knocks along the way then they move into
the spirit in the real voice that needs
to take place for the writing to be a
success but I think I heard Mary Tyler
Moore do a just a quick quote and that
was that no one gets out of this life
without something yeah which I thought
was interesting because for me I've seen
there's kind of people that have had a
lot of hardships in their childhood and
then their adult life seems to be
somewhat easier and then the reverse
yeah have you seen that oh yeah I think
I mean this what I've learned
like let's say in my own life I took the
two moments that define my voice are a
long marriage I mean a long relationship
that ended in a short marriage and
represented the death of the fairy tale
and then losing a job after 15 years
with two sister company is that in mid
pursuit so both those moments defined my
voice my voice is that of representing
the underdog the idea of overcoming
Falls and recognizing that we can push
ourselves into a direction that was even
more positive than before if we're open
to the process so I I think that you
know through understanding how to move
through that process in understanding
that a negative turn can turn you into
the direction that you're supposed to be
going then again I think that's where
the voice comes alive because you have
something to say
you